pure reason
should be divorced from emotion it
should exist in its own right even when
you're not emotional I'm going to ask
Tommy about pure reasons yeah I I'm lost
on that distinction
[Music]
I saw a reason to stop
um drinking right I saw a reason to stop
drinking too much you know reason told
me I love drinking I drank loads but
reason I couldn't I couldn't ignore the
evidence anymore this was going to kill
me right
what's the problem with that it's going
to kill you so what well I care about
not dying right is that rational is it
rational to care about not dying I mean
in a sense it sounds well of course it
is but no it isn't because you know um
there are certain Traditions which say
we should be indifferent to death there
are philosophers who tell you that death
shouldn't matter to you it doesn't
matter at all so it's not like it's
irrational
to to not to want to be happy to die
it's neither rational nor irrational we
want to live so I can't it's difficult
to think of an example where you say
like everyone yeah give you one yeah I
thought you'd think of one yeah so I
mean the philosopher John McDowell often
says you see someone in need and that
gives you a reason to act
doesn't mean that you'll be motivated to
do it sometimes we walk away sometimes
we feel very bad and sometimes we know
that we haven't had the had the desire
to do it but but you had a claim on you
to act when someone was in need oh well
okay with that that's that's okay but
that's true but that but you'll see your
distinction between seeing a reason and
that being a motivation the point is any
individual Reason by itself isn't a
sufficient reason to act right so I have
you have reasons to help he thinks it is
but it doesn't mean you can't overcome
it by your bad attitude well it's always
bad when you have a reason to help you
have a reason not to help you've got an
appointment Etc et cetera you have to
make a judgment about which of these
reasons is a more important reason to
act now it doesn't seem to me that by
rationality alone you're going to be
able to conclude that one thing is a
reason better reason than another
because rationality alone can't tell you
why it's bad that you're just taking
you're just taking the purely selfish
reasons to override it I mean let's have
I'm a monster you know I I I see
somebody in need they're dying but I'm
actually really looking forward to my
coffee so I can't be bothered my reason
I've got a reason to continue and walk
by and I've got a reason to help I I
choose the reason to go and have the
coffee that makes me a horrible person
it doesn't make me irrational does it
it's nothing irrational about that it's
just monstrous and they're different but
if you would be irrational for John
McDowell but anyway but is would that be
a reason or would that be an emotion
that's driving that again this is just
sort of my understanding of the world
but I think that emotions come first
always because
my perception of the world is a
biological
entity means that that's how I perceive
it so in that moment when you see the
homeless person but you you want your
coffee
the the decision to to to help somebody
is to do with empathy it's to do that
moment of an emotional engagement all
the reasons are there I don't have to
see the homeless person to know they
exist to do something right so actually
I mean when you were talking a moment
ago at Julian I was thinking that's
really funny because
when the pandemic started
nobody saw anything nobody really heard
anything personally but we were given
reasons right we were told yeah here is
a reason science says XYZ you've all got
to stay at home
and we did right
but I suspect most of us did it for an
emotional reaction to the information
the reason we were given it wasn't just
the reason itself that made most people
do it we all thought you know we were in
fact the media pled with us to do that
think of your grandmother think of your
father think of all these people right
but the reason I mean I thought this was
more in your your corner where you had
this nice separation between you know
our visceral you know embodied sort of
responses physiological and then there's
sort of higher thought because the
reason for invoking your higher detached
dispassionate thinking is because we
don't always have enough empathy if
you're relying on empathy to help the
stranger and you don't have it that's
bad idea so you won't say you've got a
reason to do it whether you empathize or
not so isn't isn't I mean I want you to
bring us back to that higher thought and
say what is it doing and I mean the okay
so my understanding of how this works
I'm not a cognitive scientist I should
say this completely disclaimer here but
my under standing of how this works is
we are biological organisms we have
reactions to things and emotions are a
critical part of that we see them in
animals or you know we know that for
ourselves there are emotions and we also
see importantly temporarily across our
lives children far more emotionally
disregulated than adults right so
emotion is clearly important reason
reason is what sets us apart from other
animals as far as we can tell because we
have this ability to externalize this
this thing that we can describe about
the world and pass it from one person to
another who might have very different
emotional states and emotional beings or
reference points or different parts of
the Earth have lived very different
lives and reason should stand to reason
right that's the point of it and I'm not
saying they don't feed back onto each
other and that reason doesn't elicit
emotion and I'm not even saying that
emotion can't sometimes sneak its way
into reason but pure reason
should be divorced from emotion it
should exist in its own right even when
you're not emotional I'm going to ask
Tommy about pure reasons yeah
I'm lost on that distinction so if we if
we take the examples we've been dealing
with and we suggest something like let's
use the homeless person for the example
let's say that there's a rational
process that stands away from emotion
okay so I see a homeless person there's
some a priori duty to help the homeless
person my question would be well what
happens when reason doesn't point out
that the homeless person should be
helped is that a failure of reason or is
that just not reason that causes that to
happen so what what I'm suggesting is is
that if we if we I agree that there is a
capacity that human beings have to
reflect about the world but what I'm
suggesting is that the capacity to do so
is not pure reason it's the it's the
same way that we have the capacity to
build societies and social hierarchy the
same way ants Bill and Hills reason
seems to be the capacity we have to
create justification for social order
that don't necessarily are hardly ever
in history operate individually we've
continually said that it's a capacity
that free autonomous rational
individuals have but when we go back
from whom to you know con and all the
neocontians yeah you see that reason is
very much has very much a social
function right it operates within the
certain parameters set up by the group
so in the world where the homeless
person grabs our Attention our empathy
that's not simply because it does is
because we have a construct in our
social world of a person who has a home
and a person who doesn't have a home and
that the person who doesn't have a home
is somehow violated by a social Norm or
individual failure because our Norm is
that people should have homes so there's
a normative aspect that pushes region to
kick in and this is what's interesting
in my in the work that I do on
dehumanization there seems to be a world
where the affectivity doesn't kick in
reason towards certain groups of people
so then that failure would have to say
if we're going through this separation
the failure would have to say well then
that's not rational but we know that is
rational because completely rational
educated free autonomous societies have
made decisions to group different people
into non-beings so if that if if the
social failure of not recognizing
something pulls us back to reflect on
well what then is reason versus emotion
we'd have to say something like what we
take to be a pure reason are a rational
argument for x or y seems to be a more
General be to be more located in a
general sentiment that groups have about
what they want to justify and what they
will to structure so so Tommy I want to
take that's that's a very good place to
lead on to the second theme about
whether we need to step back from and
detach ourselves from emotion to make
calmer decisions in very important
political times so you know we we see
emotion driving the mob that turned up
on January 6 to storm the capital I mean
Julian will say they also had reasons
but but emotion Big Driver of that so we
we have appeals to the law we have
appeals to the constitution in our
politics which is very divisive and
there's a lot of populist sort of uh
eliciting of sentiment isn't it
important that we have socially
constructed these rules standards
procedures by which we drop the
emotional temperature a little bit and
quartz are usually set up because people
might want to take the law into their
own hands immediately and you say well
you're not in a position to make a good
judgment here let us set up this system
where 12 of your peers will decide so
isn't isn't it terribly important to
have these dispassionate procedures
absolutely but what I would caution
though is that I would think that the
procedures we have like the rule of law
Etc are the product of someone's emotion
and effectivity so if you're looking at
the United States for instance right the
general desire that the state's not
taken down by militias and
revolutionaries is something that the
founding fathers and you know the people
in power decided hey this directly
benefits me and it's the same works the
same way in the United States with the
court system so the way the U.S court
system works is based on Star decisis so
you have a precedent and you make a
decision in the case and that case
serves as the rule that you're trying to
interpret other cases and again this
goes back to the fact there are certain
popular beliefs that we have and that
certain people in power have and then
there's a general will to make that the
more general rule by which we
intuitively grasp these ideas so on the
one hand I agree there should be general
rules that are not able to be overridden
and and overthrown simply on individual
self-justification or effectivity right
we agree on that the question is does
what stands as the rational rule of law
or Reason itself not the product of
those other groups who have the same
effectivity towards the disposition so
in the case with the Corporal you know
when they're storing the capital capital
the funny part about that is they
fundamentally believed you see because
it's not just the rule of law versus the
individual in the United States these
white people really did believe that
they could storm the capital because
they're white that they'll be completely
fine right because they're they're
supporting Trump the idea was we support
the Imperial president so the Imperial
president is a justification for our
actions right they thought it superseded
the law which in America is a completely
justifiable reason if you're a certain
population so again this is what I'm
saying is that the failure of reason or
is that the operation
yeah because they certainly thought they
were somehow defending the Constitution
absolutely and the current uh government
so so Julian I mean I let's let's go
back to that sort of case can we be
optimistic that we seek for those
Pursuits of reason that will allow us to
have social order or or Justice or
fairness Tommy's suggesting it's always
in the service of some groups sort of
emotional grounding but do you have a
more optimistic view that you know we
could actually get something which
collectively we could agree to and think
here's here's Justice here's fairness
based on reason even if it's motivated
initially by emotion
I think there's there's been a kind of a
philosophical hope the sort of people
associate I think people like Plato in
particular that you know we can come up
with these ideal perfect forms of
Justice truth knowledge and and you know
we can get there eventually and I I
think I can't really see that for
various reasons but I don't think we
need to worry about that what we need to
think about is direction of travel right
so in the same kind of way that could we
ever have perfect objectivity and see
see the world like God's will know
because we're embodied we have our
capacities of our things but can we
become more objective well yes and we
have done
um modern science is considerably takes
a more objective view of the world than
a lot of this obvious is predecessors
and so I kind of think that you know I
suppose so much of what Tommy says I
think is right and I'm not I don't want
to misinterpret him don't get it wrong
but I don't know how much you're sort of
saying
reason has has failed or whether or not
we have failed to use reason to its full
potential yeah that's what we're trying
to get and I think that's the point now
I think to its full potential let's not
kid ourselves right if we think we can
ever reach a stage where we're going to
be able to think without all Prejudice
cultural conditioning Etc we're never
going to get there but can we get
further that way I think we can and I
think there are optimistic reasons for
saying this I think that you know
there's a lot of like kicking of sort of
liberal values going on at the moment
fair enough and maybe it's not even
liberal values but I think the very fact
that there has been imperfect progress
made in the direction of you know
anti-racism anti-sexism and so forth we
shouldn't be at all complacent there
were anywhere near where we ought to be
but and you can't even
see what's happened as being progressed
unless you have some kind of Fairly
optimistic view that by
be more rational and partly the
collective thing is important I think
this is the point
um which is slight aside but
um I'm quite sort of impressed by sort
of trending psychology the social
cognition model which has said that
we're kind of a little bit hampered by
the idea that in the western
philosophical tradition we have sort of
I thought of reason as being
paradigmatically something an individual
does alone in their own head and
actually reason has evolved as a
function is a much more social thing and
I think we often make progress
rationally we reach a more rational
Society partly by having a better
Collective conversation in which we
involve more people than have
historically been evolved so so I've
gone on a bit too long Barry there but I
think the point is yet progress in this
direction becoming more rational
becoming more reasonable is something
that if we don't believe in that then I
think what are we left with oh and we
just left with a you know Battle of uh
Wills to power but let's go back to this
idea of um there being systems that we
can try to formulate and again I really
want to tease out from Ganesh this idea
she said you know we sort of you know
get Beyond ourselves we look out we're
using is it just
special computing power or does it have
a chance to embody some of the kind of
negotiation of the sort that we've just
been talking about to continue to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas